adil al-seri knows the pain and fear so
many ukrainians have experienced the
last few weeks it's become his reality
now for nearly eight years we don't get
to see our families especially my kids
haven't seen my dad and mom for about
eight years now whenever my mom calls me
she tells me are we gonna see your kids
before we die
are we gonna see your kids before we die
al cerri lives with his children near
toronto but his mom dad brother and
sisters live in santa the capital city
of yemen where war and famine mean their
lives are constantly under threat it's
really horrible and difficult especially
when we hear our friends here you know
when the family family dies because of
this war
and you know we just imagine when would
we get the news ourselves
the war in ukraine has triggered a
devastating humanitarian crisis but it
is by no means the largest in the world
while the united nations estimates 12
million people in ukraine require aid
more than 13 million people are in need
in syria afghanistan and yemen each have
a staggering 24 million people in crisis
that is a dangerous that you know the
new shiny crisis is often where the
attention is directed and so then people
do shift their donations away from one
crisis to another
it's why the un and aid agencies are now
struggling to raise necessary supports a
virtual pledge event held last week for
assistance to yemen came up three
billion dollars short what kind of
choices
are humanitarians faced with when you're
not seeing the level of funding and the
level of support that's needed
they're very difficult choices choices
alceri can't bear to consider
though he understands the pain of so
many ukrainians it pains him to feel
that when it comes to his home country
the world has looked away
heather urex west global news washington